ATISSA BANUAZIZI: So when
you're teaching students
to communicate
orally effectively,
giving them a real
living large audience
ups their game considerably.
Obviously like nobody
wants to do a bad job
in front of their peers,
in front of a group.
And obviously, that's
important because it replicates
the kind of talks that
they're likely to be
giving say at conferences.
However, it may not be wise
to throw them in the deep end
right away.
And a lot of times
in classes that do
have an oral communication
component, that's what happens.
You know somebody
isn't necessarily
an experienced speaker.
And their first experience of
it is an end of the semester
presentation, and that's
very, very difficult
for a lot of students.
So what I think has worked
really well in this class
is giving them that
practice over and over again
in a slightly
safer setting where
it's just a couple of people.
When they give the original
practice oral presentation
it's not even graded
so it's safe to fail.
And that sense of
safety and that sense
of really building up
stage by stage your skills
is what gives them
the confidence
to be skilled communicators
by the end of the semester.
You know by the time
they finish 8.13,
there is nobody in
the class who doesn't
understand what they need to
do to make their presentation
work.
And that makes it
you know the moment
of going into the conference
room or the classroom
and standing up in
front of their peers,
that makes it possible.
That makes it maybe even fun.